tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel la
mecque
on se battrait toujours dans la mosquée
pakistan premières images de l'ambassade
américaine incendiés poignée de main
chirac mitterrand rumeurs sur les
convergences gaulliste socialiste
les problèmes de l'élevage point c'est
trop de lait par assez de viande
bonsoir la vague d'antiaméricanisme qui
a secoué une partie de lorient islamique
ces jours ci en iran au pakistan mais
aussi au bangladesh et en turquie dans
une sorte de folie collective
révolutionnaire et religieuses a mis
l'ensemble du monde occidental en émoi
la stupeur passée après cette succession
d'événements qui sont comme une sorte de
croisade islamique c'est au moins ce
qu'on dit en iran la stupeur passée on
veut pourtant se garder de réaction trop
vive et manifestement les européens par
exemple souhaite que les américains ne
perdent pas leur sang froid ici
regardons ensemble les premières images
tournées au pakistan lors d attaques
contre l'ambassade des etats-unis à
islamabad et contre le consulat
américain à rawalpindi
c'était il ya deux jours dans cette
ambassade en flammes une centaine
d'américains ont vécu hier un véritable
enfer pendant des heures ils sont restés
enfermés dans une pièce du troisième
étage
fort heureusement close par une porte
blindée un refuge mais aussi un piège
doute il ne pouvait sortir ni par les
toits parmi les milliers de manifestants
qui les assiégés certains étaient armés
ils tirent et copieusement sur
l'ambassade pas d'issue non plus par les
étages inférieurs qui était la proie des
flammes
une situation désespérée d'autant plus
que la police présente sur les lieux ne
faisait rien pour disperser les
manifestants qui devenait de plus en
plus nombreux plusieurs dizaines de
milliers selon certains témoignages qui
saccagent et oublier tout ce qu'ils
trouvaient et cela parce qu'ils étaient
persuadés que la prise d'otages à la
mecque était une provocation américaine
ce n'est que six heures après le début
de l'étude que l'armée pakistanaise est
intervenu pour sauver le personnel de
l'ambassade
il était temps ils avaient tous soyez
être brûlé vie bilan quatre morts deux
américains et deux pakistanais et de
nombreux blessés
aucune victime par contre à rawalpindi
où des émeutiers avaient mis le feu au
centre culturel américain et britannique
et là aussi sans que la police
n'intervienne pour rétablir l'ordre
alors christian bousquet vient de vous
le rappeler tout est parti de la tacc
des lieux saints de la mecque attribués
par les autorités par les autorités
iraniennes et par certaines radios et
radios islamiques à une provocation
américaine on sait aujourd'hui par les
saoudiens eux-mêmes que les assaillants
au nombre de 200 étaient pour la plupart
des musulmans saoudien considérés comme
des traîtres de l'islam aujourd'hui ce
soir les autorités saoudiennes disent
avoir la situation en main mais il faut
bien le dire les informations qui nous
parviennent sont pour le moins
imprécises et même contradictoires
notamment il resterait des poches de
résistance dans la mosquée et le nombre
des dissidents seraient plus élevés
qu'on ne l'a avoué jusqu'ici on dit
encore qu'il serait très sérieusement
armés et qu'ils auraient même abattu un
hélicoptère de l'armée de l'air
saoudienne au dessus de la grande
mosquée ce que dément d'ailleurs l'armée
de l'air je le répète ces informations
ne sont pas vérifiables avec certitude
pour l'instant
alors tentons tout de même de faire le
point avec vous régis faucon
oui vous savez si les informations sont
imprécis c'est parce que les saoudiens
le veulent ainsi leurs problèmes ne pas
avouer qu'ils ont dû donner l'assaut et
donc faire verser le sang pour déloger
les insurgés
le corps en le leur interdit en dehors
de cet aspect moral se posait un
problème pratique et on comprend mieux
pourquoi en regardant vous allez le voir
cet extraordinaire photo la mosquée vous
le voyez est absolument gigantesque
elle apparaît comme une véritable ville
dans la ville avec ses innombrables
porte notamment quatre grandes portes
ici seminar et sa cour immense ici qui
peut recevoir quelques trois cent mille
pèlerins à la fois et ses 5 km entendait
bien ces 5 km de pur tour avec au centre
bien sûr la kaaba et dans son coin
sud-est la fameuse pierre noire
vénéré par 700 millions de musulmans le
problème pour les forces de sécurité
s'étaient donc de déloger les
assaillants de ce véritable dédale de
voûte d'arcade de tours mais sur ce plan
que je vous ai préparé
nous allons vous montrer comment elles
ont procédé elle enfonce deux des portes
rentre donc à l'intérieur de la cour et
les insurgés se replie dans les étages
supérieurs
ici puis dans les minarets et c'est
actuellement dans les minarets que 30
d'entre eux seraient en train de
résister alors les autorités aimeraient
bien sûr en finir avec ce qu'ils
appellent les renégats et les fanatiques
et l'entente connaîtra que bien plus
tard la véritable appartenance politique
la nationalité exacte et surtout surtout
les motivations profondes
les explications des saoudiens ne sont
pas tout à fait convaincante cette
bavure qui prend la dimension d'un
sacrilège n'a que trop porter atteinte à
des lieux dont on veut préserver par
dessus tout le caractère sacré et secret
oui et alors ici jetons un regard sur le
pèlerinage à la mecque en temps
ordinaire
cette ville la mecque située à 80km de
djeddah le centre économique de l'arabie
saoudite est réservé est intégralement
aux musulmans à 50 kilomètres à la ronde
on y vient du monde entier c'est la plus
grande concentration religieuses du
monde pendant 11 jours de pèlerinage
claude bertrand trois à quatre millions
de musulmans se rendent chaque année en
pèlerinage à la mecque pèlerinage qui
n'est pas obligatoire mais seulement
recommandée par l'islam à ceux qui ont
les moyens matériels de l'accomplir
la majorité de ces pèlerins de la mecque
ne sont pas arabes
plus des deux tiers d'entre eux viennent
d'autres pays d'asie des philippines
notamment d'afrique noire du rss et même
d'amérique et de finlande
au total une soixantaine de nationalités
sont représentées dans cette foule qui
tourne autour de la kaaba une foule où
il est difficile de reconnaître les
riches des pauvres car les pèlerins
porte la même tenue tenue sans couture
composait de deux morceaux des toques
blanches ils ont les mêmes conditions de
vie une vie aussi simple que possible
dans des centres d'hébergement situé à
proximité de la ville sainte
qu'ils peuvent accueillir entre sept et
huit cent mille personnes
la journée du pèlerins à la mecque ne
coûte qu'une quinzaine de francs et les
soins médicaux ils sont gratuits
depuis longtemps le pélérinage n'est
plus une source de revenus pour l'arabie
saoudite qui s'efforce d'en favoriser
l'accès au plus grand nombre de fidèles
le plan d'embellissement et
d'agrandissement de la mosquée sous le
règne du roi faysal avait coûté plus
d'un milliard de francs et actuellement
les autorités saoudiennes étudie un
projet pour faire recouvrir la kaaba
d'un immense dôme de cristal
le plus grand pèlerinage du monde en
revanche est une bonne affaire pour les
nombreuses compagnies de charters qui
transporte à présent plus de 60 % des
musulmans qui se rendent à la mecque
revenons maintenant aux otages de
l'ambassade américaine de téhéran cet
après-midi cinq nouveaux otages ont été
libérés ce sont des non américains ils
sont tous originaires des pays de l'asie
du sud-est dont le cuisinier de
l'ambassade
les étudiants islamiques ont voulu
distille vérifier que ces cinq otages
n'étaient pas des espions avant de
libérer n'y a pour l'instant pas
d'autres développements nouveau dans la
crise très aigu entre l'iran et les
états unis
l'homme fort de l'iran monsieur bani
sadr a répété qu'il y avait une ax que
s'il y avait une action militaire
américaine contre son pays
eh bien le peuple se battrait jusqu'à la
dernière goutte de son sang et jimmy
carter hui s'est contenté d'appeler les
amériques a prié pour la vie de leurs
quarante neuf compatriotes encore
détenus à téhéran
je vous propose maintenant un reportage
de raymond girard sur les dernières
manifestations monstre à téhéran
raymond girard dans son portage à chaud
au milieu des manifestants
c'est impressionnant c'est au cri d'
allah akbar dieu est grand que l'an
dernier
en cette fête du moral le 21 à vente des
millions de personnes étaient descendues
dans la rue à l'appel de
donnant le château le gouvernement du
général
azhari gouverneur militaire de l'iran à
l'époque avait alors fait tirer sur la
foule
il y avait eu des centaines de morts et
pourtant un mois et demi plus tard le
shah d'iran quittait le pays et à
l'appel de yatta comédie des millions
d'iraniens sont descendus dans la rue et
cette fois c'est un efi il lance à
l'amérique de jimmy carter peu importe
qu'il y en ait plus de gouvernement que
l'ensemble du monde occidental
fondane cette violation du droit
international et réclame la libération
des otages
à l'appel de l'ermite de ram 2 million
d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants sont
descendus en ce jour du maure haram dans
la rue dans un mouvement passionnel
collectif crier leur haine de l'amérique
réclamé l'extradition du chah demandé
rares allah le tout puissant de faire
éclater ce justice travu 6 qui n'a rien
à voir avec celle des superpuissances
des nantis de la terre cette communion
mystique de khomeiny avec tout son
peuple fait reculer les menaces de
représailles économiques ou de recours à
la force militaire de la part des états
unis
les iraniens fanatisés sont prêts à
aller jusqu'au bout
l'ayatollah comédie ne reculera plus
d'un tour et washington n'acceptera
jamais de céder au chantage en livrant
le chat l'impasse est donc totale et
l'on attentif à téhéran
l'ouverture des procès des otages tous
les étudiants le conseil de la
révolution ermeni lui même utilise un
bon renfort de publicité de faire
comprendre leur détermination
ce pourra alors faire washington toute
la question
raymond girard tf1 et et vous verrez
tout à l'heure dans l'événement à 21h30
à reportages plus complet de raymond
girard sur les événements en iran
sachez aussi que la révolution iranienne
et très chatouilleuse sur l'information
qu'on peut donner à partir de son pays
c'est ainsi que les 300 journalistes
étrangers de 26 pays actuellement en
iran ont été conviés par le ministre de
l'orientation nationale à une réunion
et là on les a informés que désormais il
devrait prêter serment dans les termes
suivants
je jure sur dieu tout puissant et sur
mon intégrité personnelle que pendant
mon séjour en iran je ne dirai que la
vérité éviterait de propager de fausses
nouvelles qui pourraient provoquer des
sentiments hostiles à la révolution
iranienne voilà ce que devront jurer les
journalistes en iran en défendant son
budget à la tribune du sénat le premier
ministre raymond barre a naturellement
dresser un tableau de l'économie
française dans le contexte international
la france at il dit à absorber les
conséquences du premier choc pétrolier
en 78 elle aborde maintenant le deuxième
choc pétrolier
mieux que prévu et elle est mieux armé
pour faire face aux chocs futurs en
exhortant les français à l'espérance et
à la patience raymond barre n'a pas
caché son inquiétude devant les récents
événements que nous venons d'évoquer ya
fait allusion
vous allez l'entendre nous assistons
depuis quelques temps à l'apparition de
nouveaux foyers de tension qui sont
inquiétants parce qu'ils ne sont pas
seulement des foyers de tension
économique sociale ou politique parce
qu'ils sont des foyers de fanatisme
il n'est pas facile de surmonter aussi
aisément que certains le banc
de telles difficultés mais ce qui est
nécessaire c'est que le pays sache qu'il
y a une politique claire et ferme et que
cette politique sera suivie je les dis
et je le répète le gouvernement
gouvernera et il utilisera à cette fin
tous les moyens que lui donne la
constituent je pense que dans les
circonstances actuelles il faut éviter
au pays
le spectacle de discussions politiques
stériles et lorsqu'il s'agit de l'action
gouvernementale croyez-moi je veillerai
à ce que cette action soit conforme aux
intérêts du pays
voilà donc sur la politique des partis
le commentaire de ronds de roman de
raymond barre a été qu'il fallait éviter
au pays le spectacle de discussions
politiques stériles où vous venez de
l'entendre et il parlait naturellement
de la toute récente bataille à
l'assemblée avec le rpr notamment mais
voici autre chose on n'en dit rien
encore dans les campagnes mais dans le
cercle restreint du tout-paris politique
on ne parle que de ça de la poignée de
main échangée par jacques chirac et
françois mitterrand hier à l'hôtel de
ville qui semblait illustrer les rumeurs
de rapprochement ou en tout cas de
convergence entre les gaullistes les
socialistes rumeur très à la mode ces
jours derniers effectivement françois
mitterrand et jacques chirac se sont
rencontrés hier après midi à l'hôtel de
ville de paris à l'occasion du congrès
des maires de france c'était une visite
de courtoisie a précisé bernard pons le
secrétaire général du rpr
mais lui aussi reconnu que d'une
certaine façon il y avait des
convergences entre rpr et socialiste
qu'en est il de tout cela jacques hébert
et bien imaginons un français qui
seraient partis à l'étranger à la fin de
la semaine dernière qui n'auraient pu
lire les journaux et qui seraient
rentrés aujourd'hui ils constateraient
non pas une évolution mais un véritable
chambardement politique ne voilà-t-il
pas en effet que socialistes et
gaullistes serait désormais décidé à
faire ensemble un bout de chemin
alors que ces mêmes volistes reprocher
il ya peu à valéry giscard d'estaing de
rechercher
vail majorité avec le ps ce voyageur à
prendre est tout à la fois que plusieurs
socialistes ont applaudi michel debré
lors du débat de censure qu'au cours de
ce même débat les propos virulents de
raymond barre l égard du rpr ont
ressoudé contre la politique
gouvernementale
les députés les plus nuancée qu'un
député rpr a voté la censure avec
l'opposition et enfin que françois
mitterrand et jacques chirac se sont
rencontrés en privé quelques minutes
hier après midi
et bien qu'on parle à l'hôtel de ville
d'un banal échange de propos portant
notamment sur la santé du maire de paris
et que françois mitterrand viennent de
dire qu'il s'agissait d'une rencontre
courtoise sans plus
certains vont jusqu'à affirmer qu'il ya
convergence rapprochement voire nouvelle
amitié entre le rpr et le ps il est
certes vrai que les gaullistes qui se
disent de plus en plus isolé dans la
majorité et les socialistes qui se
sentent de plus en plus mal traités par
les communistes n'hésitent plus à se
faire des clins d'oeil mais pour
l'instant il ne s'agit que de clins
d'oeil puisque on certifie de part et
d'autre qu'aucun contact officiel n'est
envisagée il faut dire que l'histoire
politique de ces dernières années peut
laisser perplexe sur ce rapprochement
qu'elles gaulliste par exemple peut
oublier que françois mitterrand a mis le
général de gaulle en ballottage en
soutenant un programme globalement
différent de celui des gaullistes et
puis aujourd'hui le projet socialiste
n'a toujours que très peu de points
communs avec les idées du rpr tout cela
semble donc faire partie du début des
grandes manoeuvres politiques pour les
présidentielles de 80 quoi qu'il en soit
pour le parti communiste qui tenait
aujourd'hui comité central la
confirmation est clair les socialistes
ont bien virer à droite
6h30 du matin
je pense que nous allons temps andré
lajoinie que lorsqu'on parle de
connivence de complicité eh bien il faut
voir du côté du parti socialiste il ya
eu comme vous le savez des convergences
exprimé par avec le parti est entre le
parti socialiste et le pouvoir
giscardien à l'occasion des élections
européennes sur une politique
supranationale et d'intégration
européenne et maintenant comme vous le
savez on parle de convergence avec le
rpr et le convergence anglais herbert ou
quoi faire et bien pour ce que monsieur
debré exprimé à l'assemblée nationale
pour faire une politique
ultraréactionnaire d' atteinte au
pouvoir d'achat de hgd opposition à
toute réduction du temps de travail de
réduction des prestations sociales et
des dépenses de la santé et pour
appliquer cela une politique autoritaire
ander fait en dehors du parlement
eh bien nous disons que c'est sont
justement ces manoeuvres politiciennes
qui doivent inquiéter les travailleurs
car il en rien de bon à nathan l'airé
les dirigeants agricoles français vont
se retrouver demain chez le premier
ministre pour leur conférence annuelle
qui permet d'examiner l'évolution du
revenu annuel des agriculteurs et
d'envisager les moyens y compris ceux de
l'aide publique pour redresser ce qui ne
va pas on a vu ces jours ci une remontée
du mécontentement des paysans des
agriculteurs qui s'est traduite par des
manifestations lesquels n'était pas
seulement dirigé d'ailleurs contre eux
le raidissement britannique dans le
marché commun contre le mouton néo
zélandais demain le nouveau prêt voudra
sans doute se montrer plus offensif que
son prédécesseur michel de bâtisses
lequel sera en face de lui comme
secrétaire d'état cette année le dossier
de l'élevage français sera
particulièrement épineux nous produisons
trop de l'est pas assez de viande
ce n'est pas nouveau mais ce qu'il l'est
ce sont les menaces européennes de ne
plus subventionner les excédents de
production
alors pour illustrer la situation de nos
éleveurs jean françois robinet a choisi
un exemple que vous voyez maintenant
6h30 du matin dans la campagne limousine
la brume se lève sur un paysage relief
agressif dévaler des pentes souvent
arides
cette ferme et celle de monsieur et
madame pasquier 60 hectares dont 40 sont
mécanisables le troupeau 50 vaches
laitières et autant de génisses à cette
heure qui n'est déjà plus matinal madame
parce qu'ils aient fini de nourrir les
veaux ici la moyenne annuelle et de 4600
litres de lait par vache monsieur
pasquier est bien placé mais il affirme
que son travail n'est pas suffisamment
récompensés
les augmentations successives que l'on
supporte les p4 5 ans font que le revenu
de l'agriculteur me suis absolument plus
ce fait le prix du lait ne suis plus lui
non plus puisque l'an dernier en francs
constants à bien le prix du lait a
baissé de 7% en francs constants
le litre de lait va être payé 110 francs
1 franc 10 donc dans une baie l'hiver et
l'été et il est bien inférieur puisque
le prix du monde mais a été payée dans
la danse 1,16 et les restes des autres
mois 0,98 parce que vous avez calculé
combien il faudrait vendre presque deux
litres de lait 200 francs le litre pour
arriver à s'en sortir parce que 200
litres de francs le litre pour s'en
sortir
aujourd'hui mon salaire correspond à un
bon chauffeur routier bien vous savez
les chauffeurs routiers
si vous prenez un chauffeur d'entreprise
qui a entre entre quatre et cinq mille
francs par mois voilà que ça correspond
5000 francs pour le couple donc deux
salaires
et cet éleveur s'estime bien au-dessus
de la moyenne nationale agricole
il est donc particulièrement inquiet des
projets européens visant à freiner la
production laitière
il regrette aussi le manque de soutien
national à l'élevage que l'erreur est
d'autant plus grand que les producteurs
n'ont pas d'autre choix est souvent que
de faire du lait des régions comme la
nôtre tels que le limousin par exemple
une région à vocation herbagère n'a pas
le choix donc n'ayant pas le choix ne
peut pas faire autre chose que de la
viande du lait d'autant plus estime
monsieur pasquier que le problème des
excédents laitiers et ponctuel et touche
plus l'allemagne que la france
et puis il y à des débouchés le tout est
d'avoir de l'imagination d'innover comme
le fait sa coopérative laitière et il
faut investir pour moderniser
aussi pour être performant au niveau de
la productivité depuis de revient et
pouvoir transformer bien sûr que
l'équipe
arrivé on avait vu des produits
régionaux typiquement régionaux puis
je pense dans les mois et les années qui
viennent verront avant important contenu
que sur le marché actuellement compte
tenu du caractère régional
équivalent un bon exemple encourager ce
que réclament les producteurs ils
demandent aussi des aides à la
production de viande
le débat sera difficile sur une prime
dite à la vache allaitante celle qui
nourrit son veau dans le pré une bonne
formule pour diminuer la production de
lait et accroître celle de viande mais
une technique dans laquelle les
producteurs ne s'engageront pas sans des
aides financières importantes
on dit beaucoup de choses sur la
délinquance juvénile beaucoup trop de
choses inexactes d'ailleurs et pourtant
c'est vrai il arrive qu'elle s'exerce
cette délinquance juvénile à l'intérieur
même des établissements scolaires et
d'une façon odieuse comme ce mini
raquette à grenoble qui s'est mal
terminée un reportage de florence schaal
thierry est restée toute une nuit entre
la vie et la mort
ils voulaient tout simplement empêché
comprend sonne un de ses copains venus
gentiment d'abord venise en compte 2 700
qu'il est
ça a dégénéré petitel titre pensé qu'on
allait vous attaquer à coups de ciseaux
comme ça non je ne le sais pas du tout
pourquoi les enfants disent rien
pourquoi je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
le mien c'est la première année où il
est là et on ne connaît pas encore mais
d'après les on dit c'est pas la première
agression qu'il y a eu et je ne sais pas
s'il ya eu des beaucoup de chance de
fait justement il faut que tout le monde
prenait conscience sur une renarde et
surtout les lycées aux alentours aussi
parce que ça ne peut pas durer envoyer
nos enfants pour les faire assassiner
c'est pas possible
son agresseur un élève de 17 ans est en
prison
il y a longtemps déjà que la violence
règne dans le lycée mais ici c'est la
loi du silence
oui c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'on leur
demande des sous l'argent et comment on
leur demande de l'argent de la dépouille
sorte les 6 go aux hymnes à ce moment là
quelques-uns de vos amis quand il a été
attaqué on renseigne oui l'an dernier ou
enfin par du monde extérieur que ces
phénomènes de rançonnage reste 10 au
secret les intéressés répugnent en faire
part soit parce qu'ils craignent
peut-être des représailles
ce soit parce qu'ils estiment que comme
ça a été le cas de thierry ses camarades
tu prends sentirais tout seul ils ont
besoin de personne pour faire face à la
situation si bien que lille est très
difficile de savoir jusqu'où va le
rançonnage caisses contenant raconté un
ami
bah il est vrai tu pas ça il y en a qui
ont été investis en commun qu'est ce
qu'on appelle le rag étage fois j'ai pas
roman est très impliqué dans le corps
situé à la périphérie de grenoble entre
deux quartiers hlm où la délinquance est
importante
ce lycée compte 2000 élèves sur 10
hectares de terrain un véritable monstre
socio éducatif tous les grands lycées
périphériques de france connaissent
maintenant les mêmes problèmes trop
d'élèves qui ne préparent pas tous les
mêmes études dit le proviseur pas assez
de surveillance des parents voilà c'est
un aperçu de ce qu'est ce que peut être
le rançonnage dans un lycée avec ce
reportage de florence schaal les autres
nouvelle avec vous éric gilbert trafic
aérien encore très perturbé demain suite
à l'échec de la négociation les
aiguilleurs du ciel ont décidé en effet
de reconduire la grève dès les collages
entre 8h et 19h et de leur côté de son
côté plutôt le syndicat des pilotes de
ligne a écrit au ministre des transports
pour faire part de l'inquiétude de ses
adhérents devant je cite le nouveau plan
de circulation aérienne qui sacrifierait
la sécurité à la rentabilisation tf1
retransmettra en direct
pardon d'abord une manifestation à bord
à paris acquis pour l'avenir de la
recherche est ce que vous voyez
actuellement les scientifiques sont
descendus dans la rue cet après midi
cette manifestation a rassemblé le
personnel de plusieurs organismes dont
le centre national de la recherche
scientifique et l'institut national de
la recherche agronomique une délégation
s'est rendue ensuite à l'elysée pour
faire remettre une lettre au président
de la république
tf1 je vous le disais à l'instant tf1
retransmettra en direct le débat sur
l'avortement à l'assemblée nationale
mardi prochain entre 16h et 18h30
en marge de ces problèmes sur la
contraception à noter qu'une amende de
600 francs pour refus de vente a été
infligée à la pharmacienne de la petite
ville de marne et en haute-saône
surnommée madame anti pilule cette
commerçante a toujours refusé les
produits anticonceptionnelle dans son
officine
elle avait été traînée en justice par le
planning familial
l'écrivain tchèque milan kundera vient
d'être déchu de sa nationalité
tchécoslovaque dramaturge romancier
kundera vit en france depuis quatre ans
les autorités de prague lui reproche
d'avoir accordé des interviews critique
ans
pays un certain nombre de journaux
france violentes manifestations en
israël contre la hausse des prix
différentes organisations mobiliser
leurs militants contre le plan
d'austérité du gouvernement béguines qui
prévoit des hausses allant jusqu'à 150%
en certains quartiers de jérusalem il ya
eu des affrontements sévère entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
le canard enchaîné a reçu la visite du
juge d'instruction le magistrat a fait
vérifier les machines à écrire de
l'hebdomadaire cela dans le cadre de l'
enquête sur dominique mari employé au
ministère des finances ce jeune homme
est accusé d'avoir fourni un certain
nombre de feuilles d'impôts aux canards
et le juge voulait savoir si certains
documents saisis à son domicile n'avait
pas était dactylographiée au journal le
prix de l'orne qui servait de support au
tiercé cet après midi à vincennes a été
remporté par yvan fans le 2 suivi de
icare le 16 et d'un fond de nous le vin
un tiercé coquet puisque dans l'ordre de
16 20 il rapporte 20 1777 francs 50 et
dans des ordres différentes 4155 france
50 l'autoroute paris lille a pu être
rouverte à la circulation en début
d'après midi il a quand même fallu trois
heures pour dégager les 50 voitures
impliquées dans le camp bleu carambolage
à la hauteur de roye dans la somme cet
accident survenu vers 8 heures ce matin
est due au brouillard il a fait deux
morts et dix blessés
oui et c'est souvent le cas dans cette
région et quand cette saison alors le
temps demain amélioration certes les
nuages deviendront plus abondants de la
bretagne au nord du bassin parisien les
températures minimales seront en hausse
mais là fini les geler en principe sur
les côtes du roussillon du sud est et
sur la corse le temps sera assez nuageux
avec des pluies ou des ondées et des
vents parfois assez fort entre ces deux
zones et bien le temps frais persistera
avec de faibles gelées dans l'intérieur
mais les éclaircies prédomineront on
observera encore bien sûr des
brouillards parfois givrants dans le
centre et le nord-est et des nuages bas
dans le sud ouest
voilà ce journal est terminé merci de
votre attention au nom de toute l'équipe
de tf1 actualité dernier journal joseph
poli vers 23 heures je crois que joseph
poli recevra le président poher four
l'association des maires de france